[Music]
[Music]
you know Bey oh why would he have a
baseball to do who you named our dude
you get a baseball yeah bro happy
Thanksgiving man Happy Thanksgiving bro
you dressed up and keep stuffing me bro
I mean touching me
I mean don't touch me like Abe Lincoln
I'm glad you dressed up bro didn't thing
dude nice bro and you never that are
beautiful is that a partridge what is
that this would be a turkey gobble
gobble it looks like a real thick pigeon
yeah it might be a fake pigeon I like
pigeons yeah you eat pigeon scent of
Turkey turkey dry ass bird bro since
when did to white its mm look at me take
me serious it's 2019 why we still eating
[ __ ] dry old chalk bird bro let's mix
it huh - Oh y'all got a dampen that bird
these I want Birds I want Birds mine
inject these batches but water something
dude I want my Birds like my Guster's I
want them juicy yeah I'm saying I want
the [ __ ] they damn thick Birds bro
yeah I want that [ __ ] juicy though
they're just not a juicy bird they're
boring they also look meanest [ __ ] and
they help baby hello and - can you look
up how often do turkeys are conjugate
can you look that up did you ever seen
them turkeys they got in the mail once
have them the net the scrotum they own
their nuts Rotem cetera and I just told
my joke twice and I wish someone had
done that hater and I heard you the
first time dude I'm sorry man dude happy
thanksgiving thanksgiving manse a day of
giving
it is minutes a day of thanks i want to
say thanks man thanks for um you know
thanks for always showing up every week
and keeping a good attitude bro i don't
always do that so i'm thankful that you
do that yeah man thank you for just
being you dude thank you thank you for
allowing me to wear it
turkey hat me a dumbass well it sounds a
little vague I think after the one I
said but you think
no I'm joking I think it was nice here
to say that dude I give you some turkey
here at my house last year for thanks
guys
that Mexican fiesta oh yeah unbelievable
bro going with him to his met his family
all comes in they're all Mexican dude it
sounds like the most raise to six figure
it's probably in there it's I'm the only
going to speak Spanish even you speak
more Spanish than Spanish
I'm like bro learn a couple of palabras
papa
happy Thanksgiving Derek what do you go
what are you thankful for man Oh bro
thankful for being able to go home with
my family I'm going back to Memphis oh
wow you're thankful for planes or what
no I like them I like being around my
family
no never see them you know last time you
saw is when we were in uh Nashville yeah
yeah it's crazy dirts tablets identical
tone but white yeah some they came to
one of our shows yeah same voice
everything we have very interesting very
crazy Berber he was talking a little
little bit thug in a little bit though I
could see it but he grow up yeah all
round black Bowling Green Kentucky gang
another real poor gang bruh he's
Newports when he's the only white boy in
the neighborhood well other than the
other poor whites he was around a lot of
poor whites but he you know he played
sports so let's I fit in where Oh
welcome my life Papa gang brah and cat
what are you guys doing for Thanksgiving
with your yeah celebrating of course we
celebrate Thanksgiving we're American
God yeah damn it Brandon you're right I
don't know if there's the biggest deal
in your culture you know cuz like Asians
it's more of a you know ya know and it's
good screeching that's alright yes
alright how about the pilgrim shout out
the pilgrims shout out to Native
Americans shout out to Indians shout out
to no everyone's just I'm thankful for
everyone yeah man I'm thankful I think
we all have a lot to be thankful for and
thankful for everybody it's rare we get
to say things yeah cuz this guy's was
like oh that's gay well it's not dude
yeah a lot of guys instead of saying
things still fart on their buddy
or the Flickerman that nuts it's like
dude I don't like you that yeah alright
yeah so it's rare to say thanks someone
man and we were part of something where
we got to say thank you
oh yeah we all know that Samuel
Adams hitter that Sam Adams hitter dude
they have a toast on one campaign and
you might have seen Brendan probably
posted his on TF ATK so this is one that
this was my toast to everyone and I
don't drink but this campaign is awesome
and so what you guys do check it out
this is why I love your steel is like
you have to toast someone you know with
a beer which is not called beverage but
you're sober and it takes real gangster
to be to be a comedian and stay sober
when I mean I'm gonna rage in Hong Kong
but I've didn't read before I became a
comedian Wow I drink double whiskey
before every set yeah so but here's
what's gangster in the discipline you
have not even entertainment it's really
gangster dude so I'm proud of you man
thanks man appreciate it it's really
courageous i night
listen i it sucks sometimes i want that
beer I bet you do that should is tasty
God I'm why it's cold on a summer day
bro but the thing about that you know I
I know some people who struggle with it
and I think your inspiration to them
thanks a lot of them don't go out and
like no I don't wanna be tempted I'm
telling me I'm be like Theo be around it
and have the willpower not to
Entertainment it's really gangster dude
thanks bro I mean you get all serious
with a stupid Turkey on my head but
let's play the app never taking you
serious but thank you for uh yeah this
campaign was awesome man let's play yeah
let's play this oh well let's play it
being Theo von it's kind of wild right
now
life's got pretty crazy it just kind of
blows my mind sometimes
I have an opportunist anyone that I want
I'm gonna toast the audience that comes
to my shows this next guy is one of my
favorite people in the whole world to
watch you see Bale and her tail I don't
drink alcohol but I wanted to be part of
this campaign because toasting is such a
simple act of kindness letting somebody
know that you recognize them letting
somebody know that they mean something
to you thank you dude
a lot of recognition these days is
liking something or sharing something
it's just so fleeting the value of that
but on the breaks let somebody know they
mean something to you
I realized the other day I look like
somebody who knows where the rabies and
Sam Adams is the perfect beer for a
toast because it has a traditional vibe
to it trying to think why reincarnation
bro you know cuz I'm planning on doing
it again you know so often I feel like
we get advertised one thing but
delivered something else people deserve
to get something for their money
you know I see a couple sitting there
maybe they hired a babysitter this is
their one night of the month that they
go out and do something fun a mother and
son that'll come out to the show or a
pair of brothers I want to make a toast
actually to you guys you guys always
continue to come back and allow me to
really follow my dream you know like
this is my dream for years how we get to
the venue and there wouldn't be anybody
there that's why it's important to me to
put on the best show you know I couldn't
live my dream so I want to toast you
guys the audience for always being there
for me and meet me in every city that I
go to anybody can be toasted it's
something we need more of telling each
other hey I see and thank them if your
next beer is the Sam Adams tonight is on
me everybody in the house and I thank
you very
[Music]
how great is that man how cool is that
pretty cool you're the boys with Sam
Adam GaSe buzz bhram gang game big bro
toast someone's pretty cool huh toast a
man who gets toasty out there toast your
bro man yeah that was cool thanks but
really cool man yeah yours is really
great too man it's alright no it's
awesome dude it's alright you know
there's gonna be associated Sam Adams
yeah and there's a neat group too is
just a neat group of people that got to
do it I thought it was pretty cool the
guy who shot a Kevin yeah he's smart
dude man yeah they did a good job it was
really cool they did a really good job
man Laurie Manus was in there Jeff cool
yeah do the comedy story - yeah yeah I'm
lucky with you don't know it's a concert
they really don't play those games where
they let you shoot and cameras around
like you thought toughest place in the
world to shoot something yeah it's like
shooting Fort Knox yeah yeah
like Fantana it's trying to shoot JFK
bro it's tough yeah I need some help I
saw yours before we played though I
haven't seen the finished product here
but man I think it's pretty badass man
that you're Shelburne you able to being
these comedy clubs around alcohol and
you're your buddy here's an alcohol like
I think it's because I don't drink it's
like yeah but lot of the audience drinks
a lot of fun dude my favorite drink is
cocaine man so that's why I don't drink
I don't have a problem drinking either
but if I drink dude there's a really
good chance on buck okay so I just can't
risk goes down to a bad road and with
that no risk your than all the coke so
sorry that was a Sam I know who's Mae
brother cuz a breeze went by
[ __ ]
Milwaukee Oh half a grand a half a gram
of [ __ ] tumeric from [ __ ] 60 yards
away sign I'll put a spice rack on its
knees
gonna be warmer tomorrow I'll be telling
you [ __ ] boy I got these crystal balls
up in here they do enough code doing
like freaking bread and stamp me do I
keep drinking
you keep snorting oh man we're gonna
enough in prison probably know or could
be awesome well we're easily end up with
probably some charges or something for
the song no one ever did something
creative without cocaine or caffeine you
feel me no I don't feel that actually I
don't feel that either that's not the
message trying to give up everything and
hopefully by us doing this you can find
when you're bros and and give them a
little cheers I'm thankful man amen yeah
toast somebody you care about you know
Derrick ooh
probably my boy Brian Simpson
what am I just my boy man a comic
comedian
yeah just funny yeah just did your mom's
house and we started together the
funniest man drawer oh just being just
the best like friend and just for being
a [ __ ] being a comedy friend just
growing through the hall this just
grinding together just coming up
together no Steven any employees Lucy
well say you might die it's horrible
sleep apnea yeah you can't breathe let
me sleep well you don't need Sam Adams
to do that okay I need a fat paycheck in
Sam Adams to do that do it that's the
message
Cal who would you toast uh I probably
toast my dad mmm nice does he drink beer
oh my god like a Albert catkin drink huh
really Papa cat can dream of a beer
belly no surprisingly shred city
he's got shred city he should have
yeah dad bought me and her dad bought
but he probably should have a gut my
grandpa has a gut and it's hard as rock
they move that's what my dad is gonna
counter disease yet yeah it is the
disease called rockgut it's called no
arteriosclerosis Brendan it was called
rockgut in the streets why would you
toast your dad though is he yeah how so
his life story is crazy
- a little [ __ ] flavor cat well my
dad escaped Vietnam lived in a refugee
camp for a year he would then he came to
America he somehow
up with this chick from Mexico who came
at a front to a house party from Mexico
visiting family members he somehow wooed
her he didn't speak English she didn't
speak English they got together he ended
up moving to Mexico for a year to be
with her you have kids with her
we think he might but we're not quite
sure I'm sure I have they got older
older brother kept Wow I'm pretty sure I
do I don't know
I wonder if you older brother watches
the show or not what he has no idea no
if your brothers and sisters watch the
show then your father had then your
father what came up here how to meet
your mom then uh family friends and it's
really weird he's like 1516 years older
than her he was a bit of a cradle-robber
mmm you dad has some game huh he's got
some game load that it's beautiful yeah
badass dude mm-hmm I like that yeah I
mean yeah I just toasted the audience a
lot of those people come out and have a
great time and it's you know it's just
crazy to have an audience man it's so
hard to get an audience in this business
or do you people have it's so hard I
mean yeah it's tough at least 16 17
years whoo
yeah yeah I always forget I said this
the other day when at The Comedy Store
you walked away and I said something
about just comedy in general someone's
like dutyies been doing it for 15 years
things I always feel like I don't I
don't know why I don't know feel like we
just do it the same ya know yeah man I
mean I was on the - I was - I'm in tour
for probably he's almost 16 years now so
yeah I think that's why this past year I
just got I just this is one of the
toughest years ever has been great but
it's also it was just a lot it was just
like man I just hit this spot time where
I was just so tired almost overwhelmed
right in the stimulus it's a lot just
overwhelmed a lot and I think it's tough
for people to understand I get it and
you're not talking about something I
think people think because you're Theo
von you have this you know you're torn
on time sold-out crowds and your pipes
going well they think oh do you have
money it's good it's like it's not about
Amy of that man yeah it's not that
doesn't equal happiness yeah I don't
have anything different I got a Jeep
Grand Cherokee now that I got a you know
paying 550 a month on but that's about
it man a nice thing I bought these hair
plugs that [ __ ] it's the fresh
[ __ ] baby drape I'm growing yeah it
does look fresh
but they haven't grown in yet but um
thank you sorry but anyhow man I'm
thankful for this show dude I'm excited
you too I'm excited yeah we're gonna do
a show refresh people should know that
there's some big announcements some
changes come up with King and sting oh
yeah the better man we're gonna do a
refresh and just kind of just do some
new just in some new segments and just
kind of just make it just kind of renew
it let's freshen it up oh it's gettin
better man yeah always getting better
dude let's kg [ __ ] up gobble-gobble
Gang Gang bro time to pay the bill oh
I'm so excited Black Friday is here and
so is movement watching the biggest sale
the year bro dude MVM t it's the biggest
sale of the year now you want to put
that arm piece on somebody she just want
to give him that wrist clock you sure
you want to give him that capability
sharing everything on MVM t-dot-com is
on sale that's hundreds of premium
watches blue like glasses Sony's jewelry
styles with a fresh new discount just in
time for the holidays any discount mmm
discount your life bro little bit
watches are an affordable option for
everybody
yep you got something special for your
arm you could put it on your wrist or
something if you want to have anywhere
mama
whoo lesbian friend you're gay for
whatever bro everybody like truck driver
it doesn't matter do somebody with
leprosy whatever somebody have no arms
and just has like a pretend arm that
they keep and they carry on this between
their legs
yeah thick ass Bulldog see if it fits on
him whatever you want you can try right
now because it's their biggest sale of
the year shop it right now movement calm
music holiday nineteen at checkout get
free shipping free returns by going to
envy empty calm holiday holiday
celebrate so shop the biggest sale of
the year right now MV mt and use code
holiday 19 at checkout get free shipping
and free return go to MVM t-dot-com code
holiday 19 at checkout join the movement
knock knock who's there an advertisement
do these suits were made for walking and
that's just what the
so one day I want that tailor-made super
Abdallah oh okay in Dutch II know bro
it's the words world's largest
made-to-measure menswear brand image
Zeus shirts coats need so much more
everything is made to your exact
measurements so you don't look like
you're in your dad's suit anymore
landlord and I know pop eh they have
hundreds of suit options for all
occasions work maybe going to the Oscars
what we're doing they got you covered
the best part is murky it's not crazy
man everything costs under $400 and
choose your fabric that package will be
delivered straight to your door in two
weeks you can get measured and design
your suit at your nearest Indo Chino
showroom or do it all yourself online at
Indo Chino calm guess what it's getting
even black or this Friday gang black up
bro black up November down the Black
Friday event is down the Black Friday
man the Black Friday event is like is
Friday gone now we give them black
tastic until December first get custom
suit for just two eight nine
$289 Wow their best price is the year on
overcoats shirts and more hit them with
more deals yeah I start your style grade
right now with $30 off your total
purchase of $399 or more at Indo Chino
calm when you enter the code cats at
checkout plus shipping is always free
free free that's hey Chino dot-com promo
code casts for $30 off your total
purchase of $399 or more it's the time
to take care of yourself you really have
no excuse they wanted to wear clothing
that don't fit yeah what do you when do
the laundry basket get your life
together endo Chino trying to keep the
lights on
alright let's do something on let's
start a little new segment boys look
who's more likely how about that huh huh
alright alright I like this first we got
tired from Michigan big Thai gang
getting buzz buzz okay bro know if you
guys recognize me
I was the dude who had the knee surgery
a couple episodes ago with the neck
brace see me now man I'm on them
baby that treadmill I'm back in action
but gang the to who's more likely to die
first in a horror movie Theo or Brendan
gang gang Congrats on the steps man
Congrats on the steps bro one step at a
time
yep take 12 of them dude and then
analyze your life yeah and it'll house
your life too and I don't know what
happened him that I'm trying to remember
do you
he was a while ago I don't remember
either but I do remember someone sitting
in something when they got there me he
lost his letter drinking I had to get me
sir no he had two legs in the video
maybe unless one of thy cattle ACOG
prosthetic Halloween Lego yeah good luck
man one foot in front of the other you
know ya gang on that middle son um died
in a horror movie who's more like let's
go to you guys you guys are better er
you guys tell us first yeah we have no
clue were like wow maybe why you black
bro you a black boot dang to be a black
boots down yeah [ __ ] they're they're
gonna send me in to do something off
we're gonna break up deal you go that
way alright gang [ __ ] bro yeah gang
shake good luck
brah they [ __ ] be killing black dudes
even [ __ ] so [ __ ] up when you think
about it dudes in Asian dudes ha broke
long but you gauge and do you think you
would keep around but he's gonna try to
befriend the [ __ ] creature and [ __ ] I
feel like they get a little wild when it
come to creatures yeah that's fair you
know that's fair can do you think would
die first
hmm I feel like you would die first only
because you would probably wander off
somewhere and then run into the killer
dr. Denley a secret meeting yeah a
secret meeting like you're trying to
find something obscure and you found
yeah and yeah I've seen too many horror
movies man you know I'm sad see way too
many way dying first come on bro bro
wreck-it Ralph don't count as a horror
movie okay you seen right graph to where
they're locked in Wi-Fi pretty scary bro
up is pretty scary when the grandmother
dies and they repossess our house with
the
that movie is Darcy Coraline Jesus huh
I've seen quite the movie super [ __ ]
dude Little Mermaid Oh dark dude
well [ __ ] did I find I died yeah that's
very coming back as a ghost dude and
I'll be in the sequel to are you gonna
haunt me huh
you'll haunt me no no no don't I'm just
gonna cause trouble dude I'm not gonna
hump you I'm just gonna cause what do
you think I'm the ghost of Darren
Sharper dawg I'm just gonna do regular
behaviours no staring sharpers called
Bill Cosby all right I admit it what do
people say do we know 63%
well with big brown damn I wonder why I
don't know I thought it was you at first
because I dances dumb I didn't want to
lose I was like oh it's Brendan you know
he goes out there but maybe that baby
that's why they thought I'd be in hell
first I'm gonna die first
uh-oh maybe they're one step ahead of us
but two steps back what did they predict
our future is dude it finally gets know
again to it what else you got we got
Richard Leo up next Oh Dicky Leo what's
up the Oh what's up Brendan Gang Gang
buzz buzz to rich you hit us with that
new hitter last week which is who is
more likely and Netflix and chills a
thing of the past so we got a new one
and Derek this doesn't go for you who's
more likely to hit that Disney Plus and
bus hey let me know who's more likely to
hit Disney Plus and bus ain't gang buzz
buzz well I got a kid I get another one
coming this you know coming up - so I
got one kid and a newborn so I need
Disney Plus you as a grown man alone
with your thoughts
you shouldn't have Disney Plus yeah I
don't want it if you do you catching
that [ __ ] Chris Hansen yeah
won't you take a seat we see you saying
your login info for Disney Plus and he
got a full set of smirnoff ice and
condoms you wanna explain something do a
steal you know a full 2 pack of Sam
Adams with like let with the lid still
all you don't wanna see I wanna cheers
you explain newest yeah I think that's
an easy one man Disney Plus and bust as
you man has to be but you got to get
neutered or you get neutered or not no I
never dude
I'll have 10 kids bro that's what I'm
saying when I was gonna make it out and
Derek you gotta have well something
should live out of whatever you've been
making all the time I can't be I can't
believe your girl doesn't have crazy
right now bro you might want you checked
out for your swimmers bro don't put that
out there that's yeah you saying black
people can't swim dude you're [ __ ] up
man aquatic I'm sorry dude I'm sorry man
you know I'm saying if I don't your
favor yeah there's a double oxy in it I
can't swim
double entendre believe ah man that's
all right man I think you're [ __ ]
brave bro I can't even imagine just
traveling out into a world every day
with different words and [ __ ] and having
a limited arsenal [ __ ] think it's
brave as [ __ ] do you like the cat and I
saw the [ __ ] vocabulary my wife [ __ ]
you're like Katniss Everdeen from Game
of Thrones or whatever hunter Hunger
Games I don't see you show up every day
in a [ __ ] battle to the end hell yeah
dude [ __ ] hell yeah it's impressive
man I'll take it
what else we got 58% Brendan vote for
you on that one
what was the thing about it they wanted
you to Disney Plus and bust oh dude that
is that yeah that does not anymore
better be in prison yeah the grown man
freaking out is there a chance to even
bust if you're watching Disney Plus like
I don't know if you do you do you do sex
to a cartoon yeah you can't like he had
shot this die me dime off Instagram
she's like oh let's watch my Juan it
seems pretty harmless
Walmart Moana drags
it does that's we get your dick out oh
wow that extended time yeah you're
welcome bro this thing it's that's that
piece yeah I guess towards the end of
the game you got to pull your dick out I
guess at the gonna make a move shooter
shoot some movies I think we're
basically boring they should just make a
movie for guys it's like hey this movie
is so boring at this point you're gonna
be able to pull your dick out yeah
pulled out here that's a great idea it's
a great idea at one point they're just
gonna screen goes yeah yeah the last
towards the end though the actor is just
winking over at your George Clooney gone
after movies just sat in a hypnotist
office like what I'm just so bored to
rather see your wiener yeah okay now
don't don't steal our [ __ ] bro
yeah paramount boy what else we got done
we got debate club boys first this is
Jimmy and Brennan from deep river
Connecticut his name's Brendan with DRC
huh Jimmy and B hey King in the stings
Jimmy and Brendan from deep river
Connecticut we got a debate club for you
what do you think you like those Freddy
cruisers of resort they're a Maui man
I've been to that resort well they're
actually in Cabo San Lucas it's alright
though all oceans like same to you good
call
well they should be a Mallee man if they
had any cool ideas
I don't like cruises bro
I don't like cruises I don't mean I
don't like being trapped on a boat this
day and age it's just where people are
killing their wives throwing them off
the boats so listen I'm not into that
dark [ __ ] cruise ship all right you
know I'm saying inclusive resorts I
don't really like either anything
inclusive all-you-can-eat can suck my
dick like all you can eat all you can
eat sushi ain't good food man or buffet
just open 24/7 you think that foods
fresh get both these out of my [ __ ]
grill dude dude look cruise around the
paint write that I apologize all right
Cruz is just a place to really douse
your spouse with that chloroform a lot
of people and that's even the old thing
the new thing is making sinkholes and
[ __ ] and hiding your wife phenol but
before that it was Cruz is two years ago
everybody's you know oh honey I love you
again and then all of a sudden you're
getting the money from the company yeah
carnival was even doing some promotion
yeah kill your girl yeah break three
yeah bring two people leave with one and
you get a dis yeah two-for-one if that
makes sense
so I'm gonna say all-inclusive you're
kind of stuck in a place Cruz at least
you get to be out on the ocean now I
like to go to college on the cruise
inter yeah degree at sea yeah I went to
college on a cruise boat from one
semester and it was great man I went
from port to port yep like a sailor bro
it was bro and stood it would be crazy
to go party sometimes with some of the
people that worked on the ship like the
you know like oh they were totally like
pirates yeah real pirates buzz I'm
[ __ ] in this party man I'm partying
what's a girl pirates name they were all
from like a Croatia or something two
women they were really talking boot ah a
couple of tough women on there in dad I
don't Filipino is two in the ship that
work on different cruises you go port to
port and oh no bro I had some probably
severe nervous condition that's a lot of
diseases spread you know that a lot of
sailors port to port dude yeah man we
didn't do we had a girl that lost a
tooth and got knocked up by a mariachi
player in I want to say Malaysia and
maybe even in Vietnam pretty close in
mariachi player in Vietnam so wild on
how do you even meet that person and
she'd biking down a waterslide and then
he was like yo let me get your tooth
pregnant yeah I'm gonna fix your tooth
of this baby I'll put a whole nother set
of teeth in your body
yes king of toasty cats dad 88% all
inclusive that's what everybody went
with yeah cruises are weird these days
and that one car like was flipping over
I saw that video yeah all inclusive you
can take some day trips it's a little
bit more relaxing I think I like being
nussle by that boat though I'm gonna go
cruise actually I'm going neither
support the podcast here's an ad dude
it's the holidays and you want to make
money the holidays you want to make
money bro so guess what don't want to
work though man yeah you don't have to
you know sports you know fighting listen
you got MBA you got NFL you got UFC and
you want to make some money it's a
no-brainer use my bookie and my book is
offering a risk-free bet on the Bears
Lions game simply choose a team against
the spread for up to $250 if you win
Congrats you've got extra holiday money
if you lose Congrats you're good
no sweat off your back my bookie will
give you all your money back it's a
no-brainer because you can literally
learning cannot lose it's no risk it's
all gravy this Thanksgiving all right
just log on to my bookie AG make your
first deposit with the promo code cats
yeah my book you will match your deposit
dollar for dollar to jumpstart your
heart and your bankroll bankroll
bankroll and that's on top of the risk
free bet weary betting what are we doing
you play you win you get paid get that
dollar boy let me repeat that guaranteed
deposit match program so that you put up
the money they put up the money they
meet new 50/50 right in the middle boy
balls in the wall you know what I'm
saying the balls in the wall daddy you
play you win you get paid ya get paid
man what you gonna do sit around
watching your great-grandfather freaking
drool that free gravy he's sucking on
yeah quit shoving pumpkin pie in your
damn mouth and go to my bookie and make
your first deposit with the promo code
cat yeah back off the cranberry sauce
you know you got sugar issues boy you
know what I'm saying tighten up and
gamble son time to buy fuel more pants
now I want to say something that's
important and also semi impor
now listening man take me as soon as you
can with his turkey on my head rock what
you sell me right now Abe I'm not
telling you anything I'm telling you
okay
I'm not selling I'm telling I'm selling
telling you that my sister is getting
figs for Christmas
oh the fruit no it's kind of a lame gift
yes ma'am Noah figs is also leg wear you
know a lot of nurses doctors dentists
how about scrubs scrubs yeah Wow like
fancy scrubs Bala scrubs people who work
in medicine and even people who work at
like uh places where they grow weed and
stuff or healthcare medical professions
yes all of us can think of a time when a
medical professional helped us well this
is a great chance to reward them with a
beautiful gift and I'm talking about
FIGS
yes half baked is an amazing committee
that is making scrubs stylish finally
make some I see my docking like dude you
look terrible now if they came in swag
him like I feel way better
figs also gives back and you can't do
every time you shop at figs they give
scrubs to a health care provider in need
around the world threads for threads
initiative Fiji baby praise God beacon
are given figs makes a great gift for
the lifesavers in your life you want to
keep living give them figs man yeah give
them fig give them fed get ready to love
your scrubs head to where figs calm
that's w e AR f IG s calm enter the code
cats at checkout you get 15% off your
first purchase by using the code cats
yeah that's where figs calm give them
figs everybody gets fix give them figs
figs down scrubs up fig figs someone's
got to pay for Brennan's coffee habit up
next we got big Zeb Stewart this bigs
ever big deal
[Music]
vo Brendon my name is Deb mother brother
Hudson got a wrestling practice here in
Lynchburg Virginia
mmm my brother just signed to wrestle at
UVA on Wednesday he was super proud of
him
wow I can't wait you know you know from
the to do well there but maybe think
with debate club three guys which were
your better years your high school years
your college years let us know gangrene
bursitis congrats you're an UVA must be
a smart kiddin right
yeah good team too bro yeah that's
beautiful that man can do all of it
hell yeah it was high school college
years my best years are right now son to
me yeah right now I'm not even close
high school you're trying to figure
things out I got injured my senior year
dreams were shattered College and an
afro I got [ __ ] over by my
african-american coach because I was
white I don't know dreams were shattered
I kept on dreaming though you know it
with dreams yeah
but you've always been you've always you
just read you read dream where you were
shaped the dream every time I think high
school really I don't fit you you were
cool in high school I wasn't cool bro I
was so nervous dude yeah I used to flex
my butt when I would walk sometimes that
make sense why ever don't I was so
nervous dude I was yeah I don't know I
was something was wrong with me and then
College Oh College was really pretty
rough call Jesse that part was the first
part was part of someone was good
everything was [ __ ] good brah no it
wasn't though bro some what stuff man
yes so it was tough but I think I always
focus on the tough part so the things
that were good dude I used to get high
and [ __ ] go I go I would get high
heels cars my neighborhood I was
sneaking and sitting there back at her
car and get high same college and then
in high school and then one time I fell
asleep in this lady's car and she
[ __ ] took me to work in the morning
she'd even know I was in the very back
it's you were about a post-office so I
got like dinner to walk home two miles
and that's when I kind of quit smoking
weed I was I'm [ __ ] this just you
athletic bro I had a good childhood bang
grew up playing sports had friends you
know it's just you know which one do you
like better though between high school
college I don't know if they're both
good man I didn't have like you know I'd
have terrible times my seat chair with
dream shadow just sports you know
yeah just friends great friends great
friends high school don't talk to him
anymore great friend in college you know
I'm gonna go high school because I'm a I
had so many friends then and it was just
I really I did better when I was around
more people and once I got into college
I think I was just around less people it
just you know it's a little bit more
yourself you can isolate more and so
once I once I got into that vein man I
was great high school I feel like it's
really it's exciting because everyone
everyone you know yeah no one's really a
loser yet because they do you know they
you know they're trying to figure out so
everybody thinks they're gonna make it
so you're all like yeah let's do it yeah
they're like three of you make it I mean
everybody knows I have I mean everybody
makes it everybody just makes it depends
what you define on making it yeah yeah
what do you guys think I said the cult
let's hit the culture cornered high
school wall Dave dog high school you
went to college
Dean what's go oh yeah I mean I just
dropped out after two and a half years
mmm but they wanted to stick it out home
for another year I can withstand it man
yeah that [ __ ] that's that real drug bro
stand up no the class when you're doing
that [ __ ] huh
can I wait a year and having it the
degree though magic waiting the your
dad's to stop doing stand-up after you
started doing it it's [ __ ] hard bro
be tough yeah what about online have you
thought about finish man they can never
take it away from your bran what'd you
get that agree unless he's telling my
mom dawg you deserve you should get it
for yourself man I just think he's sure
you can still get it yeah serve it but
you can
desert doesn't mean dropout bro you
learn that [ __ ] dude get off our land
buddy joint Phoenix online or some [ __ ]
dude I heard us even Harvard I think
pretty easy to join these days online
yeah really a Nicki Minaj part of it
any school Nicki Minaj is [ __ ] going
to but it's an ass class I think that
yeah man you should get it get slow and
take a little time but you should get it
it took me about 11 years man yeah
tell my mom it faster like the nine
years she got one slow yeah baby
but then she wouldn't got the masters in
the doctor like immediately uh-oh word
smart not to have it bruh you deserve to
have it just to have it just to have it
they can never they can never take it
away from you or anything you don't get
it for free this ain't the [ __ ] Saint
Bernie Sanders University if he deserves
end of a heart attack like that old [ __ ]
you know I'm saying can you believe that
one day if everything keeps just getting
giving everybody and it's just game be
like oh and you everybody at college
should get a degree that's gonna be a
thing when they can you believe that
great everybody's gonna have a degree
yeah what's gonna care cat you got your
bachelor's in four years like a regular
student or were you 15 17 years like
these guys um I did Community College
for two years transferred out and took
three years cuz us he was weird with
their prerequisites they made me take
everything again why did you go to JUCO
did you had bad grades no I don't want
to spend all the money on a university
for the first two years JUCO huh well
JUCO I ended up going to Evergreen
Valley College in San Jose not familiar
with not a great school shut up mark is
in the bark with they're treating what's
their name I don't even know it they
don't have a team I think I think it's
just like a bunch of like 24-year old
like Asian dudes like hey I did it like
tattoos like I didn't see my mom do I
don't know about giucose from last
chance you you feel me game it looks
like a real [ __ ] show yeah looks like
prison but with football
also known as the movie The Longest Yard
that Joey Diaz was in yeah yeah
yeah all right I think you should go
back to college in there is that the
question which this guy's what you guys
like better high school is a [ __ ] or
high school or college high school
because I think there's just exciting
it's exciting I'm having sex if you're a
normal kid like 16 and you're sneaking
around for son trying drugs a lot of old
late molest your molesters start [ __ ]
looking over at you bruh you know and
you get to fend them off though it's
like a really strong psych offender mom
yeah it's a double dragon way double
dragon hell yeah yeah gang [ __ ] what
else we got Derrick
oh man we got a of nexuses Eric this is
big Eric a loss or a debate club Theo
von Brendan Schaub gang love the show
boys so I think I have the first triple
topic debate club I think is decent all
right
hard boiled eggs sunny-side up or
scrambled a so I'm a fat way of heart I
love me some sunny-side up eggs
especially for breakfast I would love to
hear what you guys like please let me
know Gang Gang buzz buzz real egg fan
huh buzz cuz I love eggs to buzz up dogs
I like eggs if I think hard enough about
that I don't want to eat them but I like
him over medium what is that over easy
so over easy one of the real running it
masked dude I like over medium without
yolks a little firmer so didn't get all
messy yeah I like a fried egg as well
who want a burger bro come on out on a
brick not a burger bro all right no I
don't mix my beef and my bird bro ya
know I was on board with the fried egg
but then yeah mixin beef and bird is
wild and can't you guys put the eggs
right into the rice a lot of times don't
you fried rice
Oh fried rice I was so confused for a
much dang [ __ ] bro yes that's everything
with rice and eggs though he has a big
egg fence
yeah it's easy he has also [ __ ] with
other eggs like Baloo look yes yes with
your tribal oh I've had a balloon
chicken oh very scary to eat man and I
would never eat it again I all served
did you eat the actual bird or I had a
blinding I can't do that I can throw up
right now you know what it is I don't
know where this educate yourself bro you
deserve it
google it yeah it's like a [ __ ] is
disgusting it's basically a little
birthday see at an ostrich sighs [ __ ]
egg and the bird makes you just couldn't
get out so oil them Jesus Oh make him
very scared right now she needs those
every morning no he doesn't if he does
bro he's dead stir dude he's dead to me
then I'm gonna have to give him some gum
before I talk to him that's what people
eat
it's very so disturbed visceral it's
very much scientific that's one of the
reasons sometimes I don't like to over
Saad ups because they got it's like
science sometimes you cut in a thing it
still seems a little runny you know it's
like if I think too hard about any of
the eggs that I'm out bro
a twilight to go scram but I like to mix
it up I don't want to think too much
about it make it easy and I used to
drink them all drink them straight when
I was back into school and in college I
you swab the Arnold style bro I should
drink them bro eats half a stick of
butter do i do egg whites oh I didn't
[ __ ] with that yolk you guys make my son
scrambled eggs with ham I thought what
the [ __ ] are we doing dude killing this
little bird killing this pig mix them
together and then feat hidin it in your
son's body crazy dude that's insane
bro it's like [ __ ] Anne Frank of
meals Brad bro this has got to stop
man what else we got we got 9% with hard
boiled 45% Sunnyside 46% with scram dude
here's not hard-boiled in my workout
days when I want to get shred City like
Arnold I see a bunch of hard-boiled eggs
those things it's not like a fart
oh yeah dude you open those eyes are
disgusting there for senior citizens
there are people that don't know what's
going on choc yolk tourists who eat them
people that are going on you know people
that are you know like traveling out of
town to swim people that do [ __ ] like
that is not even a hard [ __ ] sitting
there huffing a sack of them
I bro you can dude it's loaded on the
freakin of waivers papa hey what else we
yeah bro you got for a relationship
advice boys keep helping folks this one
is from our girl Melissa well goddamn
girl from Nashville [ __ ] I'll go ahead
it's Thanksgiving June relationship
advice I am 29
I have sole custody of my seven-year-old
son Julia and in the past couple of
years I've dated and the men that I've
dated they're like in their 30s they
want to commit they want to be
responsible they first say they want all
the things that I want and then when it
comes down to it they dip hmm you doing
boys it's become a pattern and I'm sick
of it I've dated women in the past I do
enjoy women however there's something I
guess it's the whole real penis thing RP
RP oh should I seek older men in their
40s should I what are you date women
date anyone for a while I mean my son is
in 18 for 11 more years I don't you know
I want a companion okay she needs a
companion how much longer is it 20
seconds she had talked all night long
put its owner what you can't you can you
sleep with a boner dude
oh yeah home right away wow it's crazy
man impressive right dude this little
fine mama here bro here's the thing you
datin boys honey if it's already me call
you honey it
you're dating boys because if they're
real men they would be down with the kid
all that stuff just saying the wrong
dudes says the guy with the turkey on
his head for finance moms like this dude
just cuz you look sweet as a blink and
I'm with a stupid [ __ ] cat don't think
of me the right I'm a smart boy I'm
[ __ ] babe thinking dog yeah what's up
bro four scores and seven grams here's
what I'm saying young lady is you've got
that offspring okay you got that
beautiful Oh spring you already know
your body can work you can do magic with
that ovary so what I'm saying is this
get out there take some time off and see
what you really want make a little chart
see what you want she knows was bro she
wants a mate I know she's asking us not
to companion cuz she's saying she's
dating these dudes they sound like they
want the same thing she does a family
and the whole whole enchilada right and
then they dip out when it's finally like
time to commit with her in the kid they
dip out so she's like dude I'm dating
these thirty year olds should I date
older men forties yes she doesn't know
it's wrong saying she doesn't ask us man
or women or what should she do older
women yeah
you walk in your mouth Derek he wants
sleepy meat go with older women come
talk about it pinch me the 45 reach on
it there it's wrong woman named Barbara
mmm take care of the kid yeah take care
of her
smooth see that Turkey that barbarian
baby that's what I'm saying you're gonna
get it go to barb nah hell nah get you a
real 30 something y'all has a [ __ ]
together likes kids has Disney Plus and
busts look there's nothing out there
girl but cities in Nashville Nashville
whoo I love Nashville look stay
confident I'll say that there's nothing
more attractive to any type of man than
a real confident woman and it makes you
not want to just like a woman like that
that's a hard worker that's confident
that has their own stuff going on I
think a man can see that he's not just
gonna put one over on that lady yeah and
also dudes out there [ __ ] this this
milf don't don't waste their time and
she has kids and keep yeah keep your
crotch in your pocket too until
something real happens yeah it's just
gonna be Disney Plus no bust you Little
Busters yeah so I would just stick to
something real chill but but your girl
you're already checking all the box you
find it it's [ __ ] you're a good mom you
tab it up you got the nose piercing set
of lips you speak well about what are
you doing bro I'm trying to help this
woman out Brendan just saying if you
need a companion dude and you're over
here trying to fricking be another
problem for this lady okay you showing
up with a turkey oh yeah okay gobble
gobble gravy gravy baby trying to show
up with that head bird and [ __ ]
rattle this lady's cage bro that's you
try scrambled eggs sir you got bird on
your brain son look lady you're gonna be
fine just keep dating and one day you'll
find a prince right after that gravy
baby yeah you know what you they say you
got to eat a lot of frog to get a prince
ever eats dog I feel like we help there
bro yeah you guys attractive mama yeah
up next guys a little chide my ride real
quick ride my riot totally forgot about
this no more boat houses either man if
dude I'm see these [ __ ] car boats
ghek was sailing your house around first
this is Michele barge from Kelowna
Canada calla wanna Canada yeah that's
our dues ooh Madonn her for me for a
second gotta see what she's working on
Britton it's about the ride bro like I
see the the owner okay clearly a
snowboarder snowboard she and snowboard
right into this heart Jesus Christ what
is happening take that double black
diamond straight to my veins girl damn
bro
hey I'm bro Michelle is a ER nurse hell
yeah
BJJ blue belt mm-hmm
what's the third j4 was the second
Jaipur Brazilian jiu-jitsu
well it is pointed um that's awesome she
seems like a really attractive lady
that's doing something positive she's
outdoors in this video in this image
she's clearly a big dresser park fan
with a dress park logo on the car here's
my question now you had straight-up
dimepiece girl but here's my question
are you
are you all there upstairs and also I'm
gonna judge you based off what Jurassic
Park did you paint this then is it the
first ones which I [ __ ] with more is it
the new ones where the guy who is in
gardens the galaxy's beaten up the the
Raptors you feel me
yeah the new without one that's it sweet
the new ones just Jumanji with some
[ __ ] edits bro yeah without the rock
yeah let's be rational and here's the
thing this car is a beautiful piece and
if you drive this and do a crime or do
anything the cops are gonna stop you but
you're in that Jurassic Park vehicle
well from what we can see there's two
spare tires on one side that's the most
savage that I've ever seen it's great
that's a car that says [ __ ] we will make
it so let's see what else is pop here's
got the spoiler take that off probably
not needed and you got the bra on the
front when you got that paint no one
gives a [ __ ] if you protect the paint go
ahead take the bra off let the tits out
the front girl spoiler alert this thing
is a piece of [ __ ]
this thing should be extinct but I like
the [ __ ] dinosaurs move on well I put
the spoiler right on the front brother
said I'll hand what does anybody spoiler
on the front yeah that's a tare idea I'd
spoil her though good Lauren she's
snowboarder huh is that a tattoo on her
neck yes there it is
well that's on her collarbone but I
think there's one on our neck too you
see that who you going sizzler
what is that me here and she's a
dinosaur shirt on that's a little baby
Velociraptor pant she's a nurse man
beautiful women a lot of beautiful women
nurse nothing about a nurse man takes
care you obviously likes people caring
and if you die she could be right there
and put that sheet over you hell yeah or
she'd give you CPR son mm-hmm I choked
on a [ __ ] animal cracker to see her
nope
not faking death to meet a woman it's
called the Sandlot baby it is oh yeah
respect right I didn't burn what else
you got up next we go this our boy
Enrique shockwave oh wow he seems nice
Wow now I'm looking I'm alike it redid
the bad boy guys in 1980 this is 1980
elmer seder he needed a truck but he
couldn't afford one so I turned my bids
into an El Camino gang bruh and you got
to respect Latin culture right here man
and I'm just gonna assume I am assuming
that in a Tek is latina I think that's
fair our boys Mexican of [ __ ] that
Merced is bruh this guy has a wood panel
draw a wood panel rear of a truck trutta
a brocaded himself a back of a truck
that he fabricated himself attached to
I'm 1980 you said Mercedes a certain
light LS Wow here's the thing he cut the
trunk off this Mercedes and then
extended the back like a truck hitch
pretty sick yo if you could he's the
Mexican Steve Jobs I give this guy a job
right now yeah when you know there
[ __ ] around here this is amazing man
I've never seen anything like this me
neither dude look handling and look how
perfect it is
yeah how's it not weigh down the [ __ ]
car yeah
what did he put back there Oh anything
he wants deer antelope swans yeah
because you know you bought the Home
Depot oh he's jumping in on me I'm lady
[ __ ] pile in that [ __ ] because
chicharonnes came out honest so much is
tamales yes Jason eNOS llaves bananas
bananas but not no oh yeah I don't know
anymore right either salt chili powder
yeah yi Li Tabasco it's not chili it's
Yi Li really powder yearly drop Tabasco
yi powder powder prop you look so bad
with that Turkey dude that turkey looks
good dude yeah it does look sick I think
so let me see the back of me look like
Abe Lincoln
oh yeah the back looks dope is it sick
you have to get you look like a geisha
girl I think that know you think that
milk is gonna see this in holler oh yeah
she's in the lesbians does it do it you
look like butter ball man like I like
butt or like butter balls but yeah you
look tasty brothers like something I put
in that crisper drawer you look like
Melissa Etheridge right where's a guitar
to come to my window bruh come to my
window oh they all showed does she also
think I Drive a fast car nope didn't
treat me like [ __ ] white girl blue fish
never black fish channels bye
let's get up quick she's black I knew I
liked her is it yeah she sounds
she's huh yeah let me see Tracy how
black she looks pretty black to me from
the cover of that album Melissa
Etheridge is so white mm-hmm Melissa
yeah she'll be Goldberg oh that's Whoopi
ass would be done damn she can sing oh
yeah was she doing these days
unique yes you drive a fast car I Drive
hands being aligned yeah Julie Leslie
Jones here
sometimes you'll assess I'll make you
want to cry dude oh yeah you're right
man up so dude aren't we huh
it's Thanksgiving man thank you no I'll
thankful for Tracy Chapman Tracy Chapman
I'm thankful for Steven Spielberg I'm
thankful for Steven Spielberg I'm
thankful for videogames I'm thankful
that my eyes work I'm thankful that they
have outdoors and indoors I'm thankful
that I'm thankful for Asians who get
bowls of rice than eat outdoors like a
barbecue but they're eatin bugs mm-hmm
chin um what else man I'm thankful for
almost everything I'm trying to be what
else we got yeah before our mounting for
dads daughter I was thinking of that old
that mom something about that mom who's
also into chicks
oh yeah nice lady seemed like a nice
woman I'm thankful for nose piercings
they're sexy dude they are sexy man I
feel like you could pull off a nose
piercing really I look like a bull you
like Melissa Etheridge dude I would have
to work in a field on all four of my
legs if I got my nose pierced exactly
what else we got yes we're taking this
thing up first this is Shaun Donovan
Big Sean Sean Don Haines Tommy hey Brian
I got a king under stinger Tory
Tommy and Sarah
big fan of Applebee's Chili's those
types of places just want to know what
you guys thought all Sophie oh you look
like a live rendition of sweet little
you look like John Travolta and
hairspray that mouths brother sir chop
in his hilarious it's gonna be a circus
mouth um chain restaurants I don't
really like it myself but I have to go
off on the road let me tell you
something the go-to will blow your
goddamn mind TGI Fridays dude the rack
of ribs comes correct I've been all over
this goddamn beautiful nation trying to
barbecue TGI Fridays toot and the
sampler platter you have yourself a good
old night you [ __ ] your pants in the
hotel but it's fun while you're doing it
bro you're not gonna come correct what
you're gonna come freaking you're gonna
be a D+ student if you come in correct
with chilies and their magic or whatever
that's not a choice out TGI Fridays baby
I want my baby my baby my Chili's no
that dude is audition for that
commercial and it got down to me and
like two other dudes no I did it yeah
damn barbecue sauce that's a big one
they're like can you sing it like and I
couldn't tell the difference between
singing and saying something I couldn't
figure it out at the moment
and I was like Chili's baby back ribs
yeah I'm gonna do that right Wow yeah no
cheating my brain my brain hit a u-turn
or somewhere he got cold a second but I
was cold bro you're in that you know
like that's great innit just sing it for
us we need you to sing it and you're
just gonna couldn't do it
Chili's baby back ribs
you're Bruce Buffer announcing it was
ribs oh man in my own corner back at my
house that's where I ended up this is
what happened here bro this man is
asking about this I think i'ma go with
um
no Kane restaurants in general de GI
Friday's put all that they put that once
they went Jack Daniels on everything I
was out how bro you're you're confusing
with Chili's bro I know didn't get the
commercial but don't get it twisted also
another chain Hooters have some crispy
wings stare at tits boom nice little
parlay of a day also Outback Steakhouse
my grandma passed away
we stood go there I get a nice little 8
ounce sirloin and she would steal the
steak knife really yeah every time I was
young man that's beautiful man I love
picturing that older woman putting
knives in her foot and they go quiesce
more knives and they never figure it out
like where the [ __ ] you should be my
grandma you've dropped seven knives off
melt them down make a sword at home yeah
we had a ton of them oh if I got to go
to a chain restaurant brah go to
McDaniels brought in the middle of the
night dog sitting down having a meal
talking to your friend I'll go to
freaking Chili's bro I don't mind going
to Applebee's but I don't really like
Applebee's out are they out of business
no they're still in the neighborhood
friendly whatever the [ __ ] it's gone
yeah do you remember Bennigan's yeah
yeah they're out Bennigan's is out
yeah ventually they all fold man I'll go
to a perk and I'll go to Chile three
calendars see ya
cuz only me it was [ __ ] pies all the
goddamn Paszek why it's a seasonal thing
bro now for some people Thanksgiving you
with that Apple are you with that
pumpkin pumpkin yeah oh yeah you put a
little whipped cream on top yeah I feel
like I get a little bit older I get that
pumpkin here's something now owls for
children older yeah apples for [ __ ]
[ __ ] now that I'm older though dude
you know I do and I get
nice pecan pie a nice robust coffee dude
pecan pie and coffee that's that old man
guys like that kind of no wrong in skin
the purple yeah my [ __ ] looks like a
newborn gerbil laying down my shoe looks
like a shaved rat chillin with his
friends on the [ __ ] in the Sun bro
Wow Wow damn I never realized that thank
you so much god I never realized that my
whole life I've always been looking at
my penis Mike what is this remind me of
potato bro and it is a yam brother
praise God hell yeah thank you
what else we got man our last one boys
is Jared nap big Jared vo Brendan what
up guys is Jared in Northern California
what's up J and we're out here golfing
today beautiful Las Positas golf course
we've got a king in her sting it for you
the only World War two behind with the
boys as you're golfing I got these guys
out here my boys if his boys are toasted
oh damn
Oh a nice little swing on you let me
know what you think gang gang
hole-in-one
Mulligan Mulligan baby buzz buzz
Mulligan Mulligan
uh I like golfing you can't really drink
so it might be boring for you but when
you can drink like ice through this
charity event every year only time I
play golf me my brother cuz it have
outlawed every hole we would get last
there's so much fun you don't care about
the game just hitting it's fun dude I
broke up with a girl one time call golf
and her drinking all day with a buddy
broke up with my girlfriend and she
actually left on the course yeah she
laughed about it I got that calm I was
just bawling my eyes out that she had
left oh wait she was just saying y'all
I'm out yeah she's like fine then I'm
[ __ ] out I was like aw [ __ ] by the
time I got back I was just drunk and
dumb and then ever lost [ __ ] I really
wanted her but how long ago was that and
this is probably bad 11 years ago but
everything's okay but salad sounds like
the one that got away no no no uh for
the best why'd you guys break up uh cuz
I [ __ ] called her drunk from a
[ __ ] golf course and didn't spend any
time with her but also she i probably
there's something who knows what
happened but what I'm saying is this if
you're out drinking with your friends
yeah
get somebody drunk beat somebody with a
club drive one of those little carts
into a [ __ ] lake bro there's no
reason they put the lakes and the carts
out there if they don't want a little
bit of controversy okay agree drive that
[ __ ] in there there's water everywhere
yeah a golf course most it's gonna cost
you eleven hundred brough you can afford
it
looking for a shark bro yeah I get a
six-pack it get your own balls down
there man there's a million balls that
define those [ __ ] pawns get [ __ ]
friend out and hide that [ __ ] in a pond
yeah yeah I'm saying dude go to that
next level there's no way when men are
out there with clubs one if somebody
hasn't hit somebody and put them in one
of those things they should go looking
it's in our DNA also bro mix it up play
a little Russian roulette play when
there's lightning outside yeah you you
hit a ball in the air your buddy gets to
shoot it down with a gun yeah now we're
talking golf boy now we're talkin bro
Viet golf so let's have a let's take a
chance of some real action bro yeah
don't judge me they're buddies Tiger
Woods it get drunk with your buddies
take a bunch of pills [ __ ] some girl I
wouldn't [ __ ] some girls cuz just you
and these dudes out there does bro yeah
that's true but he's a champion for just
some guy who's just meeting up with his
buddy he's not gonna want to hear about
all wanting a [ __ ] and everything
another stylist bunny hoppers roaming
around now who do you think's bringing
the beer bro they're always time he's
pulling up you boys thirsty hell yeah
girl you guys got Snickers and Fritos
Bud Light yeah it's fun it is fun being
such a glut just cruising out there and
it's you know you've had like 30 beers
are really not that dangerous tips over
you don't give a [ __ ] how the best has
been a tips oh hell yeah oh that's fun
man oh yeah shout out to golf yeah
that's it today boys I went fast man
Thanksgiving man Thanksgiving dog life
goes fast when you grown you when you're
thankful for stuff yeah we got a state
thankful man we do man be nice each
other out there and toast someone on me
and Theo man toast somebody tell your
buddy how much he means to you yeah
toast my leads to ya send us a couple
toast videos too
yeah toast your buddies and tell us why
you did it yeah toast somebody you care
about to somebody who's your girl toast
your mom toast your cat
toast your dog toast anybody toast
somebody that you don't even know hell
yeah toast a stranger fulfillment for us
yeah man toast up peeping tom next time
he's at your window don't shut that dude
down for beer yes maybe he's just
looking somebody to talk to he's just
going creepy ways about it
toast your stripper dude he just wants
money from you now see thanks yes those
cheeks in my face
yeah what really says things yeah thanks
for being somebody you know Supriya
Pastor dude yeah if I'm a shot of vodka
yeah thank you guys for watching King in
the stinger for checking it out he
Thanksgiving I am in Borgata New Jersey
December 14th one night only bababa
ba-ba-ba-ba
and I might be December 6th at the at
the La Jolla Comedy Store on a Thursday
night might do a pop up down there I'm
their dog you are just someone there
December I think 1920-21 the Hoya Comedy
Store dude trying to get froggy drive
down to San Diego bro may I might I
might cindy is with my favorite spots
yeah man it's for you do your special at
it yeah I love it down there man I have
a man we need a bunch of pie I didn't
mean to interrupt your good gosh yeah
I'm trying to think I don't know be in
Lafayette Louisiana December 26th and
I'll be December 10th than at Los
Angeles at The Wiltern dude I'm in your
hometown next year New Orleans New
Orleans no way we're really theater at
down there yeah I know huh
that's crazy man I tell you if I haven't
been home in a long time I got to go I
know I'm in here in Kansas City to
December 6 it's the first week of
December yeah nice well turkey stuffing
pumpkin pie be nice to each other buzzer
to get me tired stuff baby gang gang
yeah big appreciate you to manage
thankful for you thanks for you boys
[Music]
the king nightstand
[Music]